[Music]
i'm going to quickly go over the energy
drink business
when people think of an energy crisis we
often think of
coal and oil and electricity and
gasoline when you think of an energy
crisis
but the real energy crisis is with
people
and that's because things are changing
as they say
and right now there's 15 million
americans who are
leaving to go to work by 6 a.m people
are working at 6 a.m so they can get off
at 3 in the afternoon
so they don't hit the rush hour right
now this is creating a huge problem
as computers begin early and new day
routines emerge more and more people are
heading to work before dawn
it's affecting the spectrum of daily
life from family schedules tv ratings
restaurant hours
and it's kind of interesting yesterday
we were going to
the meeting we had and there's this huge
line around the starbucks
people are on their way home from work
and there's like 40 cars in the drive
through at starbucks
getting their coffee and they do that in
the morning the other cough you can get
all these exotic coffees in mcdonald's
now you can get exotic coffees
in carl's jr you can get exotic coffees
and dunkin donuts
they're trying to snatch some of the
market share that was created by
starbucks
it's a huge problem things are changing
no doubt about it
and so we decided to enter the energy
drink business
because it's part of that market shift
and we want you
to have access to
these products for your customers this
is a book that
mon and i wrote called energy crisis the
whole book is about the human energy
crisis people
being fatigued and tired all the time
and if you're a doctor
85 of the complaints that people give
you if they don't come to you
as a person with diabetes or a fracture
or they're bleeding or they got
a boil or they got something they want
you to mechanically work on they come in
and say well roy i haven't seen you in
here you must be doing pretty good you
say any complaints of
i know what it is doc but i'm just tired
all the time i can sleep 10 hours i wake
up i'm still tired i'm just fatigued all
the time
got something to wake me up 85 of the
time that's the big complaint
this book is available called energy
crisis each chapter
is a history of the herbs
that are found in energy drinks
including our energy drinks
like the act and the pollen burst most
people are not familiar with herbs like
ginseng even green tea they don't really
don't know much about green tea
they don't know much about guarana and
other energy herbs typical energy herbs
so you want to be looking for this book
energy crisis
people are willing to do anything to get
energy kids sniff glue
they take drugs they get high they're
always looking for an energy
jolt they even sell water with 800
milligrams of caffeine per glass you
know really weird things
because people are looking for that jolt
of energy the oldest energy drinks
are herbs which include of course a
ginseng
very famous herb started out 10 000 bc
in china
it became an american herb when daniel
boone as an herbalist daniel boone
actually started out as herbalists most
of us think of daniel boone as the
pioneer the frontiersman
but he only became a frontiersman and a
pioneer after he made millions and
millions of dollars as an herbalist
he actually had a whole team of people
who harvested wild american ginseng
he sold it to the chinese because they
were familiar with it and as a result
he became very wealthy he became a
multi-millionaire in about 10 years
as an herbalist and then he became the
frontiersman
so all the history is in the book energy
crisis
and then there's of course guarana which
is also known as brazilian chocolate
it's a south american energy drink
guarana
and it has a substance in it called
garanine
and then there's green tea which goes
back thousands of years in china and
japan and other
oriental countries came to europe and
i'll get into the history of these
things in just a little bit
chocolate when the spanish came to south
america
the spaniards were finding a very
uneducated group of people in terms of
european
knowledge but they were highly energetic
they could run for miles and miles and
miles
almost seemingly tirelessly that's
because they were drinking
chocolate and chewing guarana and
chocolate is a huge
huge energy herb it's an herb it's a
huge energy herb it has several energy
things in it including caffeine
theobromine which opens up the bronchies
you get more air into your lungs if you
have asthma
they give you theobromine it comes from
chocolate also chocolate has peas
in it peas are phenol ethylamines which
are the love chemical that you find in
chocolate
that's why a lot of people get angry so
i was the one sending her all that
chocolate and she married roy
well that's because roy was there when
she was eating the chocolate and she
looked in his eyes
and the chemical kicked in so you don't
want to be mailing your girlfriend guys
you want to be mailing her sending her
the
chocolate you want to hand deliver it
make sure she's looking in your eyes and
she's eating the chocolate
better yeah you feed it to her that way
she's seeing you
chocolate is a great energy herb of
course there's lots of other benefits to
chocolate
it has substances in it which are now
considered the third category of
vitamins
everybody knows about the water soluble
vitamins the b vitamins and vitamin c
the fats have vitamins a d e and k and
then there's another category of
vitamins called the flavonols now
they will lower your blood pressure
lower blood sugar would they be useful
for any kind of health problem you know
well yeah hypertension diabetes
and these articles are being published
in the generally american medical
association the new england journal of
medicine
so you know it's quite true and if you
look in the book rare earth's been cures
in the last chapter there's a whole
section on essential nutrients
minerals and vitamins that book was
published in 1994 and i said then that
the flavanols will soon be considered
as the third category of vitamins that
was in 1994 and here 13 years later
harvard medical school declares flavanol
is now the third category of vitamins
because it lowers blood pressure and
lowers blood sugar
protects arteries cleans out arteries
and just so you don't take my word for
it
this came out in march of 2007
should cocoa flavon all be classed as a
vitamin of course the answer is yes
and this is from harvard medical school
epications of flavanol found in cocoa
tea and wine
could also support the diet in that it
would be classified as vitamins as
harvard researchers
and i want to jump to a point in history
in the colonies
we had the boston tea party which
occurred in december
of 1773 and most of us know there was a
boston tea party and a bunch of guys
dressed up like indians through the
tea into the boston harbor and that's
all we know well it was actually
perpetrated by a guy by the name of
samuel
adams and samuel adams was kind of a
near-to-well
thug who was a cousin to john quincy
adams and john adams
and he lived in taverns and was sort of
like a robin hood guy he stole money
from the rich to give to himself
[Laughter]
and he had a whole group of people he
called the sons of liberty which he
stationed out at all these other taverns
and when they would hear things they
would bring him information they would
decide if they wanted to do stuff and
one of his great pleasures
was to aggravate the king of england he
just took great joy and aggravated the
king of england
a lot of times he didn't know what was
going to happen he just went out of his
way to aggravate the king that was his
pleasure
and so one of the things he decided to
do was the boston tea party
and he really had no great expectations
of it other than he was going to
aggravate the king
well the king some years earlier had
instituted what was called the stamp act
and that's when they came up with the
phrase no taxation without
representation because the american
colonies did not have any representation
in the british
parliament and they wanted benjamin
franklin to be our representative in the
british parliament so
benjamin franklin was always in france
and always in england because they
wanted him to be our official
representative he was sort of an
unofficial representative
but they want an official spot in
parliament and the king said well those
are just a bunch of
heathens out there in america you know
what do they know they can't be in the
british parliament he wouldn't let him
have a member of british
parliament even though one person out of
hundreds couldn't affect british policy
and it was more of a token recognition
and the king refused to do it
so they came up with this cry no
taxation without representation
and the stamp act was a terrible choice
by the king because
it caused everybody who moved any piece
of paper like a newspaper a letter
a contract they had to pay the king or
royalty on every
piece of paper there had to be an
official like a tax collector you'd go
and and he'd put some wax on there put
the king stamp on and you'd pay him a
buck or whatever it was which is a lot
of money back then
so the king says oh i made a mistake
there because everybody in america is
angry with me so
he didn't repeal the stamp act but what
he did was lower the rate a little bit
he says well who can i tax to pay for
the war on europe
i got to make the americans pay for
their own occupation so
i'll just tax the tea drinkers because
they only make up seven percent of the
american colonies
93 percent of americans are whiskey
drinkers so i don't want to tax them
there's too many i'll just tax the tea
drinkers
and he came up with the t tax early in
1773. on december of 1773 the king sent
three british royal ships filled with
his own tea
there was a king's tea he has tax on it
so he's going to get a double
hit there wanted to help finance the war
in europe he sent
seven british men of war with all their
cannons there was a hundred marines on
each ship
700 marines to protect his team they
pulled into boston harbor
and of course samuel adams had advanced
notice of this
and so he called a meeting at the old
south church in boston
and boston at that time had 27 000
people in the population
8 000 people showed up a third of the
population showed up
at this meeting at old south church and
for three hours samuel adam revved him
up and revved him up
anti-king rhetoric people were shouting
against the king and no
taxation without representation and that
was kind of the theme of this
aggravatious little meeting well when he
recognized that the crowd was just
frothing at the mouth and ready to do
something he gave a signal
and 28 guys came out from behind the
church all members
of the sons of liberty and they were
dressed up like mohawk wires with water
paint and they'd darken their skin
and they had leggings and all the
trappings that indian warriors would be
wearing
these 8 000 people surrounded these 28
sons of liberty and shuffled them off
to the wharf where the three ships
contained the king's t were
they went on the ships threw all the tea
overboard this eight thousand surrounded
them again they went back to the church
these guys went to the back of the
church
undressed got into their street clothes
and nobody today knew who those 28 were
well samuel adams just thought well i'm
just going to stick the king and throw
his tea in the
in the bay and he thought the king would
have soldiers running around posting
notices
10 shilling reward for information into
arresting these indians
blah blah blah well instead the king
overreacted
this is something that samuel adams did
not anticipate
the king immediately declared martial
law and so if you even looked at a
british soldier
they could shoot you if you spit on the
sidewalk they could shoot you without a
trial
very heavy-handed they marched in a
squad of british soldiers into the mayor
of boston
and put a british general in as the
administrator of the city of boston
they took a squad of british troops and
marched into the governor's mansion
of massachusetts and installed a british
general as a governor of massachusetts
they came up with what was five
intolerable acts they called them
the king blockaded with the british navy
boston harbor so that american goods
couldn't get out
and no other goods from any other
country including france could get in
and that immediately started the whole
revolution because the king had
overreacted
and the cry shifted from no taxation
without representation
it shifted to give me liberty or give me
death
and that started the whole revolution
that one act and this is just
kind of like the local bandit did this
and nobody anticipated that was going to
happen
and at that point everybody said we're
not going to drink tea anymore because
that's a british drink we're going to
drink coffee and coffee at that moment
became the official american drink
after the boston tea party that's most
of the story you never hear all that
part of the story
of the boston tea party and i thought
that was a great point i'm always
looking for tipping points
like the boston tea party i'm looking
for tipping points what is going to
get us to the point where there's a huge
revolution and people stop going to
doctors for frivolous things
and save themselves and do more
themselves what's going to do it
well going to somebody who has a
relative of a friend or a church mate or
a work mate
who has diabetes and arthritis and
hypertension and coronary artery disease
and they've got alzheimer's disease and
back problems
one person has all these diseases the
chance of them listening to you and
taking
the 90 essential nutrients is pretty
slim you're trying to close the barn
door
after the horse is out of the barn so
the place to start i'm always glad to
see kids in these
gatherings because the place to start is
with kids
long before they even know about
diabetes and hypertension you get them
going
on sports drinks and energy drinks and
the pig pack plus and
the kids toddy and so it's just a way of
life with them and they're less likely
to get these diseases if they're taking
these nutrients before they get the
diseases
and they're more likely to get
interested in the business because you
know kids are entrepreneurs and they
start lemonade stands and they want to
make extra money mowing the neighbor's
lawns and
cleaning the gutters and we used to chop
wood for our neighbor in exchange for
things and kids want to do that why not
a business
they're six years old 10 years old 16
years old 18 years old 20 years old
don't leave those kids out get them
started and again i urge you to get a
hold of that book
wall street for kids so you and they can
learn together and it's tax deductible
how many christmas presents how many
birthday presents
are tax deductible starting in 1741 the
industrial revolution occurred
primarily because in england they had
burned every tree on the british isles
they had burned literally had burned
every tree in the british isles
there was no more wood to burn for fuel
and as a result
the british were forced to go to coal
they were the first people that were
forced to burn coal for fuel
and unfortunately for them the water
table is very high so they dig down 10
feet for coal
and the mine would fill up with water so
the king instructed what he called the
royal society
which is sir isaac newton and all these
very famous scientists of the day
to figure out a way to pump all the
water out of these coal mines and they
came up with a steam engine to pump
water out of coal mines because they had
to use coal because they burned every
tree
all that information's in the book
hell's kitchen when they came up with a
steam engine suddenly they could work
factories 24 hours a day
so things had to change when they had
these three shifts
how did people stay awake for the three
shifts
coffee and tea in europe was tea in the
united states it was coffee these were
the original
modern day energy drinks started in 1741
as energy drinks to stay awake during
work
and they had ropes hanging over the
machines there were loops of ropes
hanging over the machines that were
called hangovers
if you came in drunk or you had to work
two or three shifts back to back
and you knew you're going to fall asleep
and get gobbled up by the machine
you put yourself in the hangover that's
where the term came from so that you
wouldn't fall into the machinery if you
fell asleep while you were working
well these traditional and original
energy drinks are still
big business today this is an organic
tea farm it takes up a whole mountain
in darjeeling province in india eastern
india
british began cultivation in this region
in the 1830s
produces 2 billion pounds of tea a year
just from this one province
somebody's drinking tea two billion
pounds a year right from this one
province
organically grown green tea up until
1996 there was a tea board
u.s board of tea experts would taste tea
and rate them based on their taste and
color and smell
aroma and they're kind of like wine
tasters only for tea
we started in 1897 there was only
three presidents of this tea board over
that period of time
because they all were so long-lived
because of all the antioxidants they
were getting by drinking tea
kind of interesting now let's start with
some basics when it comes to energy
one of the best ways to get energy is
just to go out in the sun you stand out
in the sun for 15 minutes you're going
to get some energy
also sleep we need five to seven hours
of sleep there's an enormous amount of
research that shows
that people who sleep five to seven
hours live 10 to 15 years longer than
people who sleep
eight to 10 hours a lot of people think
they have to sleep eight to ten hours
well it's a market ploy by
mattress companies
and prescription drugs that want you to
sleep you know you see this lunesta
on tv with a green luna moth flying over
your smiling body
where you're sleeping because you've
taken the drug they've created a whole
science on sleep
you've all heard of course of sleep
apnea in the old days we used to call
sleep apnea snoring
and how did grandma and grandpa deal
with sleep apnea snoring grandpa slept
in the other room
right they didn't have to take a cpap
machine and all the drugs and all that
kind of stuff
nobody ever dies from snoring unless
your spouse shoots you for keeping her
awake all night
so why do we really sleep we sleep for
your brain to recover we don't need
sleep for our physical body we need
sleep for our brain to recover that's
why students become homeroom zombies
they sleep all the time during school
because they get too much sleep why are
they getting too much sleep eight ten
hours and they still sleep during the
day of school
because they're not getting the
nutrients they need for their brain to
recover quickly
people who sleep only five hours live 10
to 15 years longer
i get the complaints you know new people
come in they just join us and
they'll call me after a couple of weeks
or a month or so on the products they'll
call me on the radio i just love it
it's a great story and they call it and
say well does your stuff
cause insomnia i used to sleep 10 hours
a day now i drink the stuff and after
five hours i'm rolling around in bed and
can't go back to sleep
i said well did you ever complain
there's not enough hours in the day to
do things and get things done well yeah
i'm sleeping 10 hours and you know i
can't get everything done well i've just
given you an extra five hours now
get up don't roll around trying to go
back to sleep you get up and you get on
the internet mow the lawn clip the dog
walk the dog do your laundry make the
lunches for the kids
make all your phone calls to the east
coast and you know all that kind of
stuff into europe and australia
get your business done the rest of the
day you can go play golf because you got
your business done before everybody else
woke up
a lot of kids deal with the problems
well the kids deal with the problems by
drinking
energy drinks a lot of times when people
are exhausted they're just dehydrated
unless you're drinking eight to ten
glasses of water a day
you're not getting enough fluids and
dehydration will actually
cause you to be fatigued if you just
feel tired i don't know what's wrong
with me i'm just tired today
think about it how much water did you
drink drink three glasses of water and
suddenly you'll wake up
water is required as a solution to carry
things around in your body
get waste products out get the nutrition
in and of course there's a lot of big
advertising
all the various waters out there dollar
29 per half liter
or even a quarter what if you're paying
a dollar 29 per quart
that's five dollars a gallon you're
paying a dollar 29 a quart
but really when you go to a mini mart
you're paying a dollar 29 for a half
liter 16 ounces
and so you're actually paying 10 a
gallon for drinking water
a lot of exotic waters was all started
by perrier water of course
now and you don't see much about perrier
water anymore because they were beat to
death in the marketplace
fiji water fiji water they charge you
five bucks for a bottle
you know they're not shy they just
charge you five bucks a bottle so if you
drink four of those quarts
that's twenty dollars a gallon for that
drinking water i really love that stuff
the oldest modern energy drinks are soft
drinks they go back to the early
eighteen hundreds the first one that was
commercially sold was hires root beer
was the first energy drink had 20
something 23 25 herbs in it
and then next came dr pepper next came
coca-cola which was originally not
coca-cola
it was called vin martini it was
actually
cocaine was just cocaine in a liquid
form is what it was
it was ruled that it was causing too
many addictions with the cocaine and
everything
they shifted over to colon nut and so
they call it coca-cola because they went
to the colon instead of cocaine
in the 1800s and then came pepsi cola
shortly after that
and last it was 7 up most of you don't
know this but 7up
actually originated as a mix for
mixed drinks in the speakeasies during
prohibition
soda contributes to obesity by
being a stream of calories usually high
fructose corn syrup
which we know is bad bad bad high
and it's a constant stream of calories
when you're mentally deficient
i've had people tell me they drink 20 30
soft drinks a day
and wonder why they're 100 pounds
overweight soft drinks have other
dangers
the phosphates in there increase your
need for calcium
maybe 10 fold so unless you've increased
your calcium intake by 10 fold
if you drink just one soda a day you're
going to get fractures this occurs in
all ages
when i was a kid at one time i fell out
of the loft about 30 feet up
off the ground i have three cousins who
are big strapping guys i was this little
skinny
kid because i was so small they always
put me in the peak of the barn loft
and they're always pushing all these
bales of hay weighed 110 pounds i only
weighed 127 pounds
they're pushing all these bales of hay
and they're faster than i could handle
them they're just laughing and having a
good time
these guys all went into the marines and
they pushed me out of the
loft and i landed on my back and this
big cloud of dust came up my dad just
happened to come around the corner the
barn
he looks at me laying down there and he
kicks me says what are you doing
he kicks me he said get up there and go
to work you're laying around
now how many kids today could fall 30
feet on their back and not break
something
a rib a back a neck shoulder something
ankles today they're on the well groomed
soccer field and they trip on their own
spikes and fall down or somebody trips
them
in the melee around a ball and they fall
down they break 18 bones in their body
that's because they're living on
coca-cola and pepsi cola and mountain
dew
all those phosphates and also if you
drink carbonated drinks during your
meals
particularly if you drink carbonated
drinks during your meals it neutralizes
your stomach acid
so you cannot absorb minerals you cannot
digest protein you cannot absorb b12
particularly b12 is interesting because
there's a substance
produced by your stomach called
intrinsic factors kind of like a very
special mucus
that binds on with the b12 but it has to
be an extremely
acid environment it's got to be like
battery acid 1.0
acid out of a system of 14. what happens
if you drink
carbonated drinks while you're eating
your meals especially the meals when
you're taking your supplements you you
can't absorb them
there's a stomach enzyme called pepsin
which is designed to digest proteins
will it work when you're drinking
carbonated drinks during your meals and
the answer is no
because it neutralizes your stomach acid
and it requires stomach acid for pepsin
to work
can you drink a carbonated drink at
night at eight o'clock
while you're watching a football game
you could because it's not going to
affect your
stomach acid while you're eating
remember i told you about the santa
clause ad
for coca-cola they were marketing to
kids can you look at the words in here
if i were to tell you where this was
advertising you'd know
exactly but when you just look at the
keywords you're looking to
low-income minority groups of people
baby boomer age because the baby boomers
and people our age the seniors
we were all marketed to for coca-cola
and so they're still marketing to us
just like have you seen a resurgence of
marketing oldies on cds on tv
and dvds of the old group singing that's
because the baby boomers now are getting
sick and they long for the old days when
rock and roll was around
and so this nostalgia thing so they're
they're going after that market this is
not a subtle thing this is a very
direct thing so why aren't they
marketing the kids anymore because
they've lost it
the kids are not going to pay attention
to santa claus drinking coca-cola
anymore
soft drinks again or streams of calories
this kid is from indianapolis he's 12
years old he weighs 328 pounds
12 years old not genetic it's not
because he doesn't exercise
it's because he's minerally deficient
and you take in a stream of calories
from high fructose corn syrup and you're
merely deficient
you're going to gain weight lastly on
the subject of soft drinks
this was a big study in the harvard
nurses health study june of 2004
a little over three years ago it says
here the soda may increase diabetes risk
in women's 91
000 nurses female nurses over an eight
year period
women in the study who drank at least
one sugar sweet and soda they were 85
percent more likely to develop type 2
diabetes
what if you drink two you're 100 likely
to get diabetes but if you drink five a
day you're doomed to get it very quickly
there's a huge study you got to pay
attention to these things now comes the
energy drinks
this is out of an article in national
geographic magazine
they're telling you the different grades
of coffee beans and how much
caffeine is in drinks out there when
this came out several years ago
mountain dew had the biggest hit of
caffeine
but then here crumpled up on the side of
that keyboard is a red bull can
there's chocolate like m m's even
excedrin
you look at how much caffeine is in
excedrin a lot of kids just take
excedrin for the caffeine buzz
two excedrins give you as much caffeine
buzz as three cups of coffee
now people do crazy things when they get
lots of caffeine when they get a small
amount of caffeine
a total of 300 milligrams it actually
enhances your brain cognition your
ability to solve problems
in fact one mathematician who's a
professor won a nobel prize
and he said a mathematician is a guy who
converts coffee
into mathematic formulas i thought that
was kind of fun
starbucks took coffee appreciation
in america to a higher level starbucks
you remember
was the name of the first mate in the
ship of moby dick
fame herman melville first mate in the
ship
was called starbuck that's where the
name came from
and they spent a lot of time and effort
educating their customers and hopeful
customers
into the various blends of coffee from
costa rica and the
tara zoo and african coffees
this is actually where coffee started
was in africa
coffee started in ethiopia it was first
noticed
by a monk who was traveling by borough
through this little village
of mocha sound familiar but he noticed
that the goats were doing back flips and
running all over the place and jumping
off of each other and doing
belly bumps and well these are the
wildest goats i've ever seen
and all the natives there called them
dancing goats and the monk asked this
goat herder why they were doing that he
says well they eat this dark green
bush and they get crazy and he says i
just kind of like it then we sit here
watching them
and the monk sent some of these beans to
the pope
in rome and says what do i do about this
and the pope says well it's the drink of
the devil we can't have that
but he says before i put a ban on i'm
gonna taste it so the pope tasted
and he realized that he could stay up
three or four more hours each night
praying
so he blessed it and almost sainted
coffee
caffeine is a big story this came out in
january of 05
national geographic cover story why we
love caffeine it's almost the entire
issue
of that national geographic when you go
back and you look at the
marketing for coffee you can almost
smell the coffee by looking at these ads
you can almost smell the coffee just by
looking at these ads they're trying to
invade the tea
market by making individual coffee bags
instead of tea bags
you can get the little green ones for a
decaf it was very clever
because they did eat into the market
share tea because people didn't want to
make a whole pot
10 cups of coffee but you can put one
cup of water in the microwave
and put your little bag in there your
little coffee bag in there right and so
they invaded quite a bit of the
territory of the tea drinkers
with some of these ads sports drinks are
the same way marketing has a big
thing here when you look at gatorade
who's actually started
by a group of doctors who were asked
about hydration problems
in the florida gators football team and
they came up with some out of date
saline solution they just flavored it
with lemon lime drink
kind of like crystal light or kool-aid
and the florida gators drank it and they
won all their games that season even
though it was unseasonably
hot it was a record year for heat but
it's a marketing
more than actual effect there's only two
nutrients in gatorade there's a hundred
nutrients
including 77 certified organic plant
derived colloidal minerals
in rebound fx and sports tech and sports
toddy
if you notice the wording here in the ad
hey they don't drink it just to psych
out the competition
they drink it because it works or drink
it because these guys are all having
this camaraderie and fun gatorade was
actually
a factor that was created by these
doctors at florida state university
they took it first to coca-cola because
they were the biggest soda company they
said would you take this on as a project
and they said well
who's going to buy sports drinks and so
they went next to pepsico who said
oh yeah we'll take it and so gatorade is
the biggest source of income for pepsico
they own 85 percent of the market's
share of sports drinks it was the
smartest thing pepsi ever did
was take on gatorade but we have rebound
fx and sports tech and sports toddy
have a hundred nutrients in them we have
some with green tea in it
so you get some caffeine we have some
without the flavor
berry boost the rebound fx does not have
green tea in it so there's no caffeine
in it
you get the energy from other sources
and there's no sugar added
you know the story of theo ratliff how
he brought him back from a career that
was ended all the great orthopedic
surgeons said his career was over
we rebuilt him using the 90 essential
nutrients and he's had 140 million
dollars worth of contracts
since the great orthopedic surgeon said
his career was over
so you think that stuff works yep well
he loves us and as a result he's one of
our spokespersons
for rebound fx which we really designed
for him highly absorbable liquid
supplement supports healthy exercise
promotes optimal well-being propriety
formulation
supports cardiovascular health boosts
stamina energy great taste
and then when you really do a scientific
comparison
of rebound fx versus red bull versus
rock star versus gatorade versus
powerade
guess what there's a hundred nutrients
including the 77 plant derived
metals there's no other sports drink or
energy drink that has the 77 certified
organic plant minerals
look at gatorade only has two nutrients
sodium and potassium 100 i mean which is
better
we have to work hard to beat the
marketing of pepsico
now many of you have tried pollen burst
pollen burst of course
came on the scene in 1976 1976
1972 and 1976 the olympic long distance
team
for finland won the 10 000 meter in the
5 000 meter
olympic runs and after 1976 the up john
pharmaceutical rep went to them and said
are you
taking some stuff what is it you're
doing to win these racism is just
year after year they won the same long
distance races they said well we're
taking flower pollen
and so it was actually up john
pharmaceuticals that came up with pollen
burst originally
it's a pollen green tea energy drink
very unique it's non-carbonated in
individual pouches and you just tear
open the pouch put in 16 ounces of water
shake it up or you can put it in juice
and drink it
it's just a great energy drink i
wouldn't recommend it late at night
unless you want to stay up all night
because it does give you an enormous
amount of energy but you don't get the
jitters because the energy really
doesn't come from caffeine
it comes from other stuff and it's a
wonderful drink tastes great kids love
it
in fact you can give it away at
halloween instead of candy
at the door put your name and phone
number on it tell people hey if
are you interested in your own energy
drink distribution business talk to them
about pollen burst
on each packet it has all the
ingredients in it so parents can look at
it
today you're going to learn about act
try it feel it love it is the theme of
course
for act it's a very unique energy drink
in a can
we also have the non-carbonated pouch
which i love to drink during meals
because it's non-carbonated
the can you can drink anytime you're not
eating or taking supplements
it originated as this non-carbonated
pouch
same formula exact formula except it was
dry powder with no
carbonation the first 20 months they
sold
12 million of these little pouches just
20 months
in 30 minutes we first came out with the
cans of act in the first 30 minutes
400 people in the room we sold 500 000
cans to those 400 people they're so
excited about moving from the pouches of
the cans the pouches still today
are a bigger seller than the cans
because people like the non-carbonated
version they can just put in a bottle of
water
the act is actually bottled by the old
switch brewery
in memphis tennessee or canned i guess
you say is a sliced brewery
all the employees when schlitz went out
of business they sold the bottling plant
and the canning plant to the employees
and the employees do all this bottling
for
starbucks they do the canning for red
bull
and they do the canning for act well
with act you
certainly have the product to meet these
trends remember we have a new trend now
the younger people come along
and we're displacing soft drinks with
the energy drinks
you have the product you have the
compensation plan you have the company
you have the support
you have the power to carpe diem which
is latin for seas today
knowing what you know now what are you
going to do about it or will you take
advantage of the growing trends and
profit from them
and move people from coca-cola and red
bull to
sports tech to sports toddy to rebound
fx to act to pollen burst
what are you waiting for we've also
added
what they call the act berry bar and the
act berry bar is very similar to our
nature's way nutrition bar the dark
chocolate on top of the raspberry flavor
and so that was their first real solid
product they got everything else's
liquids
so they love it the act berry bar
energy bar with act you're going to be
able to
be paid several ways in a ct you're paid
weekly
you qualify you got to qualify and act
you're paid weekly
and you also get paid in the form of
points
just like mileage points with airlines
and hotel
stay points like the old s h green
stamps when you're old enough to
remember those things
there's a awards booklet these award
booklets
have mud bikes for kids they've got
walkie talkies and
gps things global positioning stuff you
can use in your car to find your way
around
pool tables all kinds of nifty stuff you
can actually use the points for more
product
so what's your plan the average age of
retirement 67 years old 85 percent of
retirees live their lives in poverty
the american average net worth is only
50 000
my favorite statement by albert einstein
my favorite nobel prize winner
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and expecting a
different
outcome make the decisions make a change
now join the multi-billion dollar energy
drink business and market
because the retirement system as we know
it is a rip-off
when a company declares chapter 11 that
allows them
access to take over all the retirement
money and you lose all your retirement
so what happened when kmart bought sears
now wasn't that a neat deal here's a
company that was in
bankruptcy chapter 11. kmart was in
chapter 11 bankruptcy and they turn
around and buy
sears now why did sears allow that to
happen
because they could get into the
retirement money and get themselves out
of financial trouble
it was all about the getting at the
retirement money so it was about
so now the employees have any more
retirement because of that
merger isn't that neat
well how do you prevent that you build
your own retirement
to build a business is going to give you
another income stream plus tax
deductions you're silly
not to do it to be able to keep your
house and not have to sell it because
you can't afford the property taxes
isn't that worth a couple hours a week
of course it is
pay off your 30-year mortgage in 10
years unlike other energy drink act
combines a high power of an energy drink
with the benefit of nutrition
what is missing so you get all the
energy
and almost none of the sugar there's
only five grams of sugar
for 12 ounce can of act try it feel it
you'll love it
on the go packets are grab and go cans
here's these little packets they come 30
in a bag
or you can get the kind of a big wide
mouth jar for the powder in it you just
use a scoop
or they come in little boxes like this
with five of the packets in so we can
put your name
on there and use it at trade shows and
sell them for a discounted price or give
them away as a premium
or advertising oh this is my energy
drink business
how'd you like to join me partner up
join the multi-billion dollar energy
drink market over the past five years
the energy drink market has grown an
average of 50 percent per year
this is from the mintel energy drink
report in 2006.
goldman sachs predicts the energy drink
market will hit 10 billion dollars by
2010.
that's only two years from now 10
billion dollars within the last five
years going five years from zero
to 10 billion do you think it's a going
concern
yeah and so this is not an obligation
for you but i want you to know that
there's a huge opportunity here remember
we talked about shutting the door
after the horses out of the barn if
you're going to build a huge energy
drink business
you have to include kids you can go down
as low as six years old
anybody between six and eighteen has to
have a responsible adult sign
with them jointly signed we also have
available now
for a very low service fee i don't know
i'm guessing now three dollars a month i
think it is three dollars a month
a debit card system we will wire you the
money
so you get your money five days earlier
saves us money we don't have to pay the
postage and pay people to stuff
envelopes with checks and print the
checks and also
but you're going to get your money five
days earlier goes into a debit card
it'll cost you 30 to 50 cents depending
on your bank
to send all or some of that money into
your accounts your regular accounts
but what about a 10 year old kid or a 16
year old kid has his own debit card now
you take 40 of whatever money comes in
there you put it into a car
account for the car or the truck or the
jeep and then you put 40
into their college fund and you let them
keep 20 percent
for their jing their walk around money
right going to mcdonald's or their hobby
shop
on their debit card you're going to
start them in business you want to go
through this book with kids even if
they're six years old you want to teach
them about money and banking
and the difference between being an
employee and
a business owner a small business owner
versus a big business owner
now there's nothing wrong with being an
employee if you also own your own
business
if you're only a good employee you're
doomed for a miserable life as you get
closer and closer to retirement
maybe even while you're working but when
you own your own business you're
constantly building that income stream
building your number of distributors
building your equity in your own
business
getting all those tax deductions getting
most of your withholdings from your job
back because of your little business
it's a different life
suddenly now you can do all the things
that doctors do wall street for kids
and it's tax deductible the last one i'm
going to share with you
is an antique print a little drawing
from dun and brad street in 1841 that's
when they started 1841
dun and brad street so watch it look at
this little thing i'm going to give a
word picture
you can't do business from an empty
wagon john bradstreet started by
fronting wagons for guys who wanted to
go out and sell stuff salesmen they
didn't have the money the capital to buy
their own wagons
so they'd loan them a wagon they could
work towards buying it you know owning
it themselves
and they give them product on
consignment and they go out there and
build a sales route you can't do
business from an empty wagon they came
out in 1841 you've all heard that you
can't sell out an empty wagon you can't
do business from an empty wagon
that came out in 1841 from dun brad
street i thought that was just an
amazing piece of information
if you want to be a big distributor you
personally cannot just be on auto-ship
and take orders from your customers and
spend a lot of time educating them
you say well it's gonna be eight to ten
days for you to get your product
we're gonna send in your order it'll be
eight to ten days i'll say oh okay
and you're gonna do they're gonna run to
the health food store they'll buy
something similar
well your order's here oh no i i want to
return it you know i went to the health
food store and got something
so to prevent that when you sign
somebody up you want to hand them their
product right then
when you go to a home party for some of
these other companies or they take
orders no
you get your product right there at that
home party they don't want you going any
place else or
today you can go on the internet and so
you have to have a little bit you don't
have to have a million dollars worth of
inventory but if you have a couple
hundred bucks worth of inventory
i mean where else can you start a
multi-million dollar business for ten
dollars
information and statements regarding
dietary supplements discussed
have not been evaluated by the food and
drug administration
and are not intended to diagnose treat
cure
or prevent any disease
[Music]
thank you for listening to this
presentation and remember to contact the
person that sent this to you
for more presentations and books that go
into greater detail
go to doc wallockmedia.com and be well
these statements have not been evaluated
by the fda
these products are not intended to
diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
the opinions expressed in this
informational program
are the express opinions of joel d
wallock bsdvmnd
are not a replacement for proper medical
advice and treatment
in all cases we recommend you contact
your physician directly
regarding any medical conditions